welcome to spoil the corner for infinity
war that was harsh
spider-man accrued I think in particular
retard Bella
yes but it's a friggin comic-book movie
you know of it but it was very Lord of
the Rings like I want to go sure yeah
okay I get that that's why I fucking
look I know it's the way he calls him
sir it's got a very Marcy Peppa daddy
feels anyone that fades away in that
dust you know it's coming back out
I think Loki and Gomorrah are gonna come
back time I think this is where okay
having not read the sink since 93
I don't remember Loki in it I'm trying
to remember like and then Gamora there's
so many cuz they kept going on with the
in the infinity war like that they were
like three of them basically like so I
want to say how was it Drax get sucked
into a soul gem like a couple people get
sucked into a soul gem I think warlocks
in the soul gem like I think directs I
forget if Gamora was involved with it
but I feel like with what they did at
the end that gamora's stuck maybe in yes
that's what I get cuz you're not gonna
ban that Thanos is looking at like the
little kid version of her great scene in
that flashback by the way as soon as he
saw her is just like you know hello like
that I am like I am in still way in love
with this villain i okay so so the scene
where nano is again where we're guessing
you've seen the movie boiler corners
yeah these are spoilers the scene where
Thanos throws Gamora into the pit and
stuff like that I had a few issues with
that mainly because you have to throw in
something that you love and I thought
there's gonna be a twist like well you
wouldn't destroy something that you love
but no there was no - I don't know the
second he
throw himself in know ii know this she's
trying to put it together like oh come
on audience it's like five snow like
that yeah that's that's what made me
laugh because it's like so you have
thrown something to well that was like
well by gomorrah like and she's like I'm
just like really you can't put this to
get like no okay um but first of all
it's like okay cinematically I kind of
understand why she went kidnap but when
he turns around with tears she's like
haha tears and it's like it's not tears
for him it's like the second she puts it
together
no the second she sees the tears that's
what she should have been like oh shit
first time she sees a motion to nitpick
but it is also lightly sliced there I
feel like you could have been more
cinematic with there her realizing
without him let's go let's friggin in
this got a huge reactions back even got
there he's like sucked into the cube or
something was that I yeah I love Hugo
Weaving so I thought maybe that was
gonna be mistress death for a cig was
like oh maybe they're bringing him like
no they're not okay we're just coming at
character I am Hugo talk yeah he was it
was cool to see him again there's a
badass fight between like it just opens
with a badass by fan yeah Hulk will
fighting if he just kicks Hall to ass
bets word I started smiling like and I'm
just like this just feels right
like everything feels right about this
right now I'm like I'm in ok hands like
I was worried by the trailers ok so
again this is more the opening but so
we're right just everyone that was
escaping from thor ragnarok they just
all fucking die yeah like movie
pointless doesn't this is I mean it's
like oh well we didn't need to stop by
here we don't need to do any of this we
could just data well half the universe
is dead right now so you know I guess is
she stayed there if what's her name keep
a lanchette just stayed there and took
over more people would have lived
then if thought you have sick them all I
you think the data come back well yeah
well and this is where I could confuse
cuz like I don't remember
like him wiping out half the universe
that was always this goal I don't
remember doing it though
so now I feel like I have to go read
them all again because it's been like 25
years or something but I and just like I
don't know where we're going with this
because I don't remember that
necessarily happening and we're missing
like a couple principal characters so
I'm just like they may be going off
these two guys may be going off on their
own like tangent but that's the thing
it's like it's comic book movie and if
you like guy you can reverse time
there's all sorts of things like there's
obviously a way out of it and I feel
like if you want to bring thoris people
back through that you can do that if you
want to bring bad gomorrah like i'm
convinced but the guardians of the
galaxy considering how popular then
there's like there's no way she's dead
I thought for a second they were gonna
kill iron man off right there I really
audience literally just went oh well you
see how this is my ever heard house he
was saying that he was you know gonna
retire the character you know he's kind
of dying it's like dude I've been doing
this for 10 years it's like fair enough
I mean honestly but yeah I think
everyone just thought oh he's dead okay
we can talk about that okay
I had my a menacing - it is weird
well my issue is just dr. Strange's
whole thing is like guard
the time stone or whatever he says I
will sacrifice you in a second if it
means protecting the stone yeah and so
fan oh this is like overkill iron man
I'm gonna do it and he's like way in is
you know
American accent getting better but it's
this wait if you spare his life I will
give you the stone and I'm like look at
it I'm like to say well I'm like oh just
that and I'm like I'm like we're talking
about half the universe and you've
dedicated your mystic martial arts
bullshit life to doing this it is just
like here take it and I'm just - two
things because I thought the same thing
yeah so wait he was building this up
suddenly he does it it seemed way out of
character me but I do have an out so
two things popped in my mind one cuz he
says dan'ichiro says why did you do that
nay said were in the endgame and the
thing that pops in my head is that one
he realizes he's smarter he can figure
out a play he needs to live you know if
you guarantee he lives I'll probably die
a lot of people that but you'll live you
can think of something - no no no no -
he looked into all the million other
ways you know all the million
possibilities they said oh yeah he says
there's one we can get out and it
probably involves him living it's I feel
like that's closer I feel it has
something to do with the fact that it's
the time stone and I'm like here's all I
feel I don't know where exactly going
but somehow looking back on it I don't
think that was just like oh it's the
value of friendship it's like I feel
like he's just like I have a plan like a
long game plan but it's like he needs
like a plan is you make a plan I don't
know if they've already kind of butting
heads but I feel I feel like that's the
thing I I feel like strange came up with
a plan and I'm like okay apparently he
needs to hand the stoner because
otherwise I'm just like that just was so
out of character I'm just like no dr.
strange would let him Tony Stark died if
I'm saving half the universe actually I
wouldn't look like here's the thing I
think because what's okay what's the
name of Ben & Jerry flavor what's dr.
strange he you know call it martyr MOCA
before the powers what was he he was a
doctor yeah you know and he needs the
stone to do all these cool little
effects and stuff like that and my reiki
needs he needs the stone to do kind of
that stuff or no dr. strange I forget
but but regardless I don't know I don't
think so cuz he didn't get the stone til
didn't have it at the beginning when he
was practicing all them shit yeah well
maybe by kids about gar I think it's
about guarding but Stark he doesn't have
any powers he makes all this shit
mhm so I think there's a you know it's
something where they're already butting
heads because they're already very
similar characters I mean people who can
point that out to a fall so I like that
they don't get along and their
counseling start
arguing who has the better plan and
stuff like that and I think it was kind
of a way of him acknowledging I think
you're going to come up with a better
plan
it's like acknowledging his intelligence
is greater than his so that's that's my
foot org like I said that this I reality
I think he's I think he's got some sort
of hatched plan where the only way to
make it work is to hand over the stone
but men it may involve travel cuz you're
gonna have to travel back in time or do
something considering everybody just
turned into you know dust in the wind
like okay that's the part we're talking
about what we're saying kids are gonna
be scarred just seeing friggin
spider-man or it is biker boy died in
well that was hard
yes that was really hard I don't want to
go I was like damn and a Groot I'm just
like no none grew you know you're like
oh yeah everybody's like dead silent as
everybody's disappearing that Groot
starts disappearing and didn't back the
iMac so you just see me so what and I
thought that was you know again most big
movies would have the music guy you
could have good music by keeping its
silent having this be the infinity war
everything's been building up to it just
closing on a quiet no Silas
uncomfortable awkward no dark like it uh
it's a dark movie like when I really
think about it's like Loki gets
strangled in the beginning sorry
Hiddleston fans may be getting okay but
and it's it's a brutal scene as eyes are
turning red they feel like they're gonna
pop out and he's like struggling like
I'm just like and that's like the first
few minutes I'm it's like after
everybody else on that ship is mass Kurt
I'm saying I'm just remember just
sitting there thinking oh yeah give me
that kind of movie okay whoof and I like
when they say you're not coming back
this time he's looking at the audience
like he's really dead because he's died
so many times really mean it this time
the the scene with with little Gomorrah
and everything shot behind her it's at
the freakin killing fields going on back
there
that was super dark Gamora sister
getting tortured there was like dark
everybody disappears it's like what this
movie was really dark yeah
and just thinking of all these kids
going up to the legs I can't wait just
to see ya I actually gonna be from
parents I feel like this I mean and
great
it's pg-13 again this is you have to
assume Rea but it'll mean something they
don't make it easy cuz PG means G now
and pg-13 erratically means PG but so I
get it but it's like this is the pg-13
yeah and it's it's not Temple of Doom PG
third but no but it's definitely more
hardcore than some of the other like
Marvel films that can pretty much be PG
they just throwing us where yeah most
Marvel films I think could be PG yeah
but yeah and I just like it I because
that's why when the movie ended I mean
like the movie just yeah let yeah the
movie ended I'm really like people like
it but it definitely was it was like
that Empire Strikes Back and thing where
it's like wow and everybody lost Wow
like even Empire hand like you know the
hopeful music gonna be okay this just
sends what they're going huh oh God and
fans in this little like cottage from
Heidi or something just well that's what
he was gonna say like I'm gonna go and
I'm gonna watch the sunset knowing that
I just murdered half the universe oh
what a good day like I know there's
something you know this is one of the
few times to were the vagueness of his
plan again I think it's because his
performance is so good and the
technology boom is so good where it's
like the vagueness of his plan I find
fascinated thing sees it as mercy it's
like I only killed half I don't kill the
other half well no okay so how bad about
balance that comes from the Infinity
Gauntlet and the affair more comics it's
he's maintaining the balance of the
universe and then he's also working for
this character that doesn't exist miss
not appearing in the picture
mistress death and is also trying to
kind of court her at the same time so
it's that's always been his thing that
it's almost like an ecological thing
like the way you call deer or basically
shoot a certain number
dear so the population doesn't overgrow
and like he explained and I thought
pretty well in the movie and I didn't I
didn't feel it was really vague it was a
little more vague compared to the comics
cuz he had nobody he was working for or
trying to impress or anything but I was
pretty much I know where this guy's
coming from and he completely thinks
he's right and like honestly I'm like
once he showed his plan and I'm like
well maybe he's got a point and some kid
like you know the Morris plan it's like
hey your planets doing just fine now
like so but it's but yeah that's the
interesting thing about like a villain
like man it's just like yeah that sounds
great at utopia but it's just like
you're also just killing a bunch of
people it's like that's messed up like
it so I don't know I I got and I I
thought it was I got I got it enough I
mean it still to a point where I'm like
if you were to ask me do where'd this
guy come from you know where but what's
his backstory I'm like well thanks play
a little bit but like not that much but
again I'm I am okay because it really is
kind of episode of fact I don't need to
know you Doris from yeah you go mess
around without an X but there's so much
already to him you know in his character
and his expressions and his lines and
yeah for a character that has just been
the most least interesting out of
anything in the Marvel movies every time
you showed up I'm like I don't care I
always think of the honest trailers if
we've got Thanos said he still doesn't
do jack yeah he then he looked awful in
those movies he didn't look interesting
and here I mean it's just like complete
reversal I mean just like immediately
interested in this guy and just a great
merging of a performance and technology
I mean we always where they go from here
cuz like in the comics like black just
shows up the giant like planet eating
like I don't know how to help a guy do
like ant-man and wasp and get up - barb
yeah play nuts
um maybe well cuz they they hit that cap
tomorrow at the end and again I'm
thinking like well maybe it may a wasp
and Captain Marvel they'll be like
before this that's the only thing you
were talking about that like me will
sort of see what happens like before
start fading away but they've done that
like nothing kind of did that before
didn't they with Thor and Hulk being
gone in yeah I see I like how Hulk has
become the Winston of the team oh yeah
that's right you've been missing allow
us to explain a couple of these plot
points to catch the audience up like
it's the sleepy also but I like it cuz
I'm just like it's like what a handy
excuse just like oh yeah that's right
you've been gone for two years yeah the
Avengers split up and I'm not talking to
Captain America anymore it's like oh
okay well if I miss that movie at least
now I know what's going on cool you know
the it's interesting because he's Hulk
only for a little bit in the opening and
then he never comes back and whole just
goes no no and did they ever really
explain why is it just as he was Hulk
for so long and thor ragnarok is that it
or did they don't blame that remember
almost like it was something I didn't I
love that there's so many and I'd be
like I got enough of him and Thor
Ragnarok I'm gonna be nice to some flat
point thing where they're just building
up to where he unleashes in the sequel
and it could be yeah I mean that that's
a good point anything we're like well
this was kind of weird it's like just
like how all of the team members are
kind of split up into different groups
yeah and we know I gotta come together
in love you know and won't that be cool
when out of the ash you literally all
the ashes they'll come back and they'll
all be united and they'll be even bigger
I will say with that ending though no
with that anything like we're waiting
for the the end credits like little
thing after the credits was like I would
kill if it's just Stan Lee it's just
like that's it folks the whole series is
over
fake trailer don't we just put a bunch
of scenes together with no movie the
Lord Lee giveth the Lord lead taketh
away that's it the whole series ends
right there with half of everybody dead
he's just sitting there like you know
smoke in a thousand dollar bill and
there's the watcher look at him just
going so let me say it's just people
that die usually even though again I
feel like I feel like most if not all of
the two yeah two big ones that may be
more of a question mark Loki and
Gomorrah yeah but anybody wants anybody
that disappeared in that you know poof
of you know there I I feel like Gomorrah
is coming back I don't know how you get
rid of that kid or or she comes back and
it's a different like maybe if the
actress wants out so she's slightly
different but I'm like be you you don't
get rid of Gomorrah Guardians with them
but those Loki I'm just like his Loki
was such a popular character I feel like
getting rid of him people although she
does kind of wrap up near the end
doesn't cuz it's Thor Ragnarok he
finally does kind of come around either
side so I mean this would be kind of a
fitting end but and even though they do
show Thor accepting it uh I still feel
like it's like man that's Loki though
like that's a huge character I feel like
there have to be even more time I don't
know educate it to that so so I don't
know but yeah can't can't think it too
much else I'll say the only care even
more and may I look I never thought I
loved it when one of them says there's
an ant-man and a spider yeah my two
favorite lines in the whole movies of
the first was an early one with a stark
just what were they telling it's like
well you need to do this again I thought
I needed to go dairy free but then Ben
and Jerry's named an ice cream flavor
like there's some reason I lost it and
then the other one that we both lost our
shit at was just and where did you get
that armor this is like then how
how much for the gun is not for sale all
right how much for the arm and he just
looks at Bucky walks away these just
like I'm gonna get that uh yeah I'm
gonna get better that's just I love it
because I could totally imagine stealing
that arm in the middle of the night well
one of my favorite lines very early on
because I realize it really comes full
circle
yeah Chewie is from Bogomil Qin yeah he
says we have a Hulk and I'm just like I
mean right there I just always serve
that was brilliant that was pretty
brilliant by the way if you're watching
when a proper down Junior's talkative
with Paltrow though watch his sweater it
did
it's a and then it's off just like I
know that an IMAX it's easier to notice
that's something I forgot to mention
Gibbs no that's um I forgot to mention I
hate watching movies and IMAX where the
aspect ratio changes and I get why they
do it but it drives me and I hate seeing
those black Bart's and they're gone then
they're there then they're gone
not in this movie the whole thing shot
in IMAX and you can kind of tell us a
little bit more headspace you know on
lower space and stuff like that but I I
felt that was so nice because it did not
distract from anything going on it's
still a particular aspect ratio because
you're thinking of like Dark Knight
where the IMAX selections most small
most movies what yeah no I like anytime
there yes he specifically shot he's
specifically shot on know by me like
concentration I did that a lot of these
movies dude I have they don't K well
that's the same aspect ratio but I don't
know what the proper I like cousin
listen dunkirk done to cover the entire
i'ma cuz the IMAX screens like us no no
no no no III the same thing of a black
bars no blackberry pie but it was not as
noticeable in Duncan yeah I mean aspect
ratio
no the whole kind of shot this is shot
in IMAX but again you can tell when it
comes to blu-ray and everything they're
gonna there's a lot of headspace and
there's a lot of jest so I mean they are
gonna be crop it I'm sure but but I just
really like it cuz that's a nitpick when
I see that in IMAX movies and I get why
they do it but it was nice seeing a
whole IMAX movie like the whole way from
beginning to end
what else what else and I was saying the
one character I say she she
not in it long but it just made me
realize I'm like yeah I won't get into
this character oh I don't get into
Pepper Potts in the slightest like when
he's going on the ship
she's like Tony you you come back here's
a I can't know you come back in right
now you come back here and I'm just
thinking I said you know this was a cool
character she fucking go get a rocket
ship go after his dumb ass and then
she'd be a part of the opposed just like
just it's like who likes a character
like that nobody likes a character like
that they they did tease that and I ran
three with sort of put in the suit on
and I I'm not like I never just liked it
I never liked it like I like Pepper
Potts just fine there's there's no
character in this I dislike I just they
didn't give her anything to do you're
right like it's just wasn't there she
just calls and says come back so it's
like that's the writers fault though
like if but you kind of just needed her
there just to reestablish that there a
thing remember like weren't they broken
up in one of the movies or something or
not like I thought I told you enough I
can't wait I remember now
Ironman know that I'm in three but like
I want to say like Civil War maybe
because they were also in spider-man
yeah or at homecoming like I'm totally
less like it I this is just like really
reading comics and yeah that's all right
find the one guy who's gonna nitpick
this is actually an issue for three of
them but if you've been reading all your
life you're just gonna forget some stuff
that's going on forever yeah it's just
all those things around like thousand
one thing I was just like where she's
like in the Iron Man suit just like
whatever a little lady iron woman or
something like that like that'd be cool
but she just still seems like that what
about it's no okay that would have been
cool but I liked Pepper Potts I just
think the problem is then we can really
do die I don't just like Pepper Potts
try saying it three times fast pepper
potts pepper potts pepper potts
but dislike from this movie yeah um tell
Thursday's spoilers that you liked or
disliked or the ain't surprises that
really caught you off-guard
uh did you bring any kids and was there
any kid just walking it was a blank page
if this is another kid just in their
seat just oh man is a little kid being
such a spider-man fan yeah that just
beeped out about asked me up never asked
me up for a bit I would have been I
would have been walking around in two
days for a couple days like I just saw a
grave of the fireflies
[Laughter]
spider yes there's no meaning to life
it's all just chaos so that's about it
we'll see you guys next time
later dad yeah
you